a buddy of mine is a coder he made a
product just using AI it wrote all the
code freaky I can't do that because I
don't know how to code I don't know how
to read codes I don't know if it's good
or not if you're an expert what used to
take you 90 of your time which is
generating things and then 10 was
validating what you had generated or
quality assurance you now expand most of
your time to using the machine to
generate and then you spend your time
doing QA and making tweaks that's how
you can 10x your output using these
tools just like the internet and an
iPhone you become more valuable to the
companies that you work for or the
clients that you serve